China's central government is condemning
protests in Hong Kong following another
weekend of unrest protesters clashed
with riot police on Saturday and Sunday
more than 60 people were arrested
government officials say the violence
has caused serious damage to the city's
international image rule of law and the
lives of residents ramie Inocencio has
been covering the protests for the past
two months good morning this is the
first time China's central government
has ever held a press conference linked
to Hong Kong's affairs ever since the
city it returned to Chinese rule back in
1997 Beijing has condemned the violent
protests and urged calm protesters
demanding more freedoms and pushing back
against Beijing clashed in street
battles with riot police firing tear gas
and rubber bullets across Hong Kong
Sunday night protesters tried to reach
the city's top Communist Party Building
but police repelled them with more fury
than before advancing leaves that are
dancing they're running into the
processes police hold people away but
more protesters using guerrilla tactics
threw down signs and threw back tear gas
on Saturday unprecedented chaos near the
border with mainland China a week
earlier angry mobs had beat protesters
and bystanders in the subway police
response time was slow in the past
minute or so police with wounds of
course we live in fear down
this weakens escalation in violence is
now the new normal for one of Asia's
most international and financial cities
with neither the city's protesters
government nor Beijing willing to
compromise Beijing also said it stands
firmly behind Hong Kong's embattled
chief executive Kerry Alam protesters
have demanded that she resigned so this
is unlikely to end and
time soon for CBS this morning rainy
Inocencio Hong Kong all right ray me
thank you